we do a lot for single moms on this show
right so it's just something we've done
over the years and you were raised by
your mom right yep
cool so we wanted to just surprise a mom
today and just call her
we're making an initiative this year to
donate twenty thousand dollars to single
moms just hitting them up
and um just giving them 500 on the spot
it's not a big thing but
dude if my if somebody would have called
my mom and gave her 500 bucks dog
it's huge to see my mom get like a new
dress or just be able to get her hair
done do something for herself
that's a that's a car payment plus more
yeah depending what car you got
hello brittany hello
hey hey is this brittany yes
hey my name is theo um i'm just calling
uh
uh your sister nominated you um
i just wanted to call and chat with you
about something can i call you on
facetime for a second
sure it's nothing perverse or nothing
like that
okay yeah everybody it's fully clothed
yeah so i'm gonna call you back on
facetime and just put your phone
sideways too
okay okay cool
let's make it a thousand bucks huh
hey can you hear me or not yes
okay cool um so yeah so we just i i i
work as a podcaster so we just do a show
and um
i was raised by a single mom and i'm
sitting here today with kane brown he's
a musician
and um he he was raised by a single mom
and his grandmother
and um or his nana sorry and uh is that
right
mama and then mom and nana so anyway we
know that you're a single mom and we
just try to do something all the time to
do something sweet
so we just wanted to send you a thousand
dollars to do something fun for your
daughter
madison so it's we're not trying to be
weird or anything we just thought it
would be
just something nice to do nope
i'm not kidding this cane kidding i'm
not kidding i'll tell you i'll go ahead
and add another thousand dollars how
about that
dang cain is rich cain is rich honestly
so now you got two thousand two
thousand so
what does your daughter like to do
i'm speechless well that was sweden kane
i didn't know he's going to do that
thank you bro yeah man that's nice of
you
um um my daughter is
she's 10. she
she's got a good little mixture of
tomboy and girly
features that's just like canel's done
and playing in the dirt
okay okay
um well what's something fun you guys
would go do what's something fun that
she likes to do
um i i own a jeep so we drive around in
our jeep
quite a bit yeah you go go off-roading
every once in a while but
just driving around in the jeep is
something that we do
together she loves shopping
she loves um
she loves everything she's just such a
great kid
oh that's sweet we've recently
wanted to go on vacation but
unable to uh copen really
well you could go to florida with two
thousand dollars you could go to florida
it's open
you know that's crazy
i i don't even know what to say
thank you oh you're welcome yeah we
didn't mean to put you on blast either
we just
we were just talking about it like i
remember my mom growing up like
if somebody would just come out the blue
and just done something just to
offer just a little you know just
something nice where she could go do
something fun
and man it would have been man it would
have just made me feel good as a kid to
see that somebody cared about my mom and
it would have just been
a little bit easier on my mom mm-hmm so
um
well look you can put a lot of gas in
that jeep with 2g so there you go
well look we don't want to mess you up
on your lunch break or anything but
um yeah we just wanted to say thanks for
being a hard-working single mom
and your sister nominated you is that
right
yeah i think your sister nominated you
because she listens to to this podcast
and um yeah we just been trying to be a
part of single moms lives for a while
and so we're just
nice to meet you and i look forward to
meet you in person when i come in in
town to do a show
wonderful thank you so much
okay you bet be good bye
bye oh well that's
a sweet lady huh oh yeah um
thank you brothers nice of you yeah man
damn i didn't know he's gonna come over
here and have to spend a g
bruh but there you go that's cool that's
awesome man that's good
um so uh so we'll also we'll have to get
our tickets to restless road then bro
definitely well they'll be on tour with
me so oh they will yeah so we'll just
have to send her send her some tickets
dang bro hope you enjoyed that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option
not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one
you